fraid Hayley's a married woman she's  Marie she's taken off the market with  these fans these Hawaiian fans do not  stop now what is it about Hayley and  Elijah that you think is just so  mesmerizing for these fans um I don't  know I think I think it's a combination  of both of these characters I think  within this kind of very heightened  supernatural dark world very honest  characters and really just want kind of  the good out of people and so I think  they're very kind of similar souls in  that way and I think they want the same  thing and I think they've both gone  through faced a lot of adversity  throughout their lives and you know I  think in a perfect world they would be  together and just make each other happy  because they've had to go through so  many awful things in their you know  ineffective lives and it would be like a  nice happy ending so I think that's  other fans